the problem with most people here is
they're onedimensional or just on
Instagram and you don't think there's
too much no I don't think there's too
much you're going to post tomorrow and
nine people are going to see it there's
8 billion people on
earth right but let's say you got
LinkedIn or whatever platform serves up
the people who interact and engage with
your stuff right remember when I say
four or five times a day six times a day
I think you need to be on seven
platforms so it's not six on LinkedIn
I'm talking about Twitter x Facebook and
then inside of it there's it's Facebook
and Facebook reals it's in Instagram and
Instagram stories it's Pinterest tons of
people here should be doing stuff on
Pinterest not even thinking about it
linkedin's a monster for everyone here
Facebook still a monster YouTube shorts
is a monster YouTube long form monster
there's a lot going on the problem with
most people here is they're
onedimensional or just on
Instagram